this book was inspired by the birth of
your son
yeah i didn't think i cared what the
gender of my child was
until i saw the sonogram right and then
they they told me the splotch was a
penis
and i suddenly just freaked out and i
pictured having to teach that penis like
how to play baseball and that penis
wanted to go camping penis doesn't have
to know those things
that you teach the boy and the penis
comes i didn't know how it worked it was
all very confusing
so you were and i i know what you're
talking about because
uh sometimes you can have moments of
being intimidated as a dad i have a
six-year-old boy
and you know you go to throw the
baseball with him and then you're trying
to remember wait a minute i want to make
sure i'm doing this right it's been a
long time since i threw a baseball i
never threw baseball
right so i had to go learn all this
stuff you know from the beginning
because when i was a kid i like
i had a glass animal collection and i
had an easy bake oven
wait you had an easy bake oven yeah that
you could make cakes right in your own
room
right i would layer them in manly ways
with frosting and stuff
but yeah i was i was basically a uh i
was a gay man trapped in a straight body
yeah yeah you understand i do yeah all
right
this is incredible here we go this is an
incredible encounter
now did you you you talk about one point
you you went to go get your testosterone
level checked yeah you wanted to get
your testosterone level checked yeah
well i was concerned
uh so i had you know this testosterone
thing became a big deal it's like 10
years ago for a column for time magazine
i got my testosterone check and my
doctor is sick of me asking him to do
stupid things just so i could write
about it yeah so he
he did it and he told me it was totally
normal
and i pressed him for a number and he
refused to give it to me
and then eventually he did and it was
like barely normal i was like two points
on the guy
side of testosterone so now suzanne
summers has been tweeting me last week
telling me to start taking testosterone
which suzanne summers she's very i know
about this she's concerned
about guys testosterone wait why is
suzanne summers concerned about men's
testosterone
and why do you know about that because
she was on oprah talking about when she
if i'm not mistaken for for women she
would rub
a hormone on her vaginal area
and so
wait why what would that do you realize
we're not talking about your book
anymore
fine with that wait what what are you
talking about so nobody why would she
rub
male testosterone oh and i'm not sure
without without misquoting her it had to
do with
love like her ph levels and it may have
had to do with cancer if i'm not
mistaken and it's too rebalanced
go back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah vagina go back to just vagina
uh okay so it's a cream and not a gel
it's a cream yeah where is this cream
available
i bet i bet suzanne summers.com
but i was glad because it's not a shot
which i would never no no
manly guys aren't gonna take shots no we
real men like creams